This is tungsten, I think.
Tungsten is a very hard and heavy element.
It has a number of very important uses. It
is used in the filament of light bulbs, the
ordinary sort of light bulbs because it has
more or less the highest boiling point of
any element and therefore you can use it as
the filament and it can get very hot without
very much evaporation on to the walls. If
you add iodine in the gas around the bulb
you can run it at even higher temperatures,
the so called quartz halogen lamps and sometimes
you see these in up-market cars.
Yes, it’s tungsten. So this is tungsten.
Tungsten is used as an element material to
form the very, very fine wire that we may
have used in old-style electric light bulbs.
It is a really quite wonderful metal and it
is actually used in nature. But here we have
a really quite beautiful sample. This is a
single crystal of tungsten which is mounted.
Tungsten carbide, the compound of tungsten
and carbon is used in the very tip, the balls
in the tip of a biro pen or ball point pen.
Really quite amazing. I have got some other
tungsten here somewhere and in fact here is
a very fine wire of tungsten and this is precisely
the material which was used in the formation
of very early electric light bulbs. A really
quite amazing metal.
There is also quite a nice book by Oliver
Sacks, who is an Englishman who now lives
in America, called Uncle Tungsten. There are
not many books that have chemical names in
the title and this is a story of his childhood
and how chemistry really had a big effect
on him.
That’s lovely.